at cpac at the conservative political
action conference bruce jenner showed up
because he's running
for governor of california and he was
heckled okay
and i you know i don't like this sort of
i think it's ugly to just go heckle
public figures all the time
uh this is par for the course for anyone
who's in political life so it just comes
with the territory and it's just the way
it is
so it's not as though bruce jenner is
special in this regard but still it's
always ugly when it happens so he was
hackled he was referred to by his actual
sex he was called a man rather than his
imagined sex
and he was asked a completely fair
question which is what he thought about
transgenderism being taught in schools
this is a radical
false theory about human nature that
your body has nothing to do with who you
are it is being taught in schools the
guy who's running for governor of
california was asked about this
he obviously buys into the idea itself
because he's living out that idea and so
i think it's totally fair question
the heckler was rude as happens to every
politician but but the question was was
totally fair
tommy lauren who is a conservative
commentator
i think she's on fox fox news and fox
nation
tommy objected to this tommy wrote on
twitter quote
the attacks on caitlyn jenner are
despicable i'll go to bat for her
every single time and if you want to
take my conservative card for it
take it and shove it your mob is no
better than the left's and in fact it's
uglier hold on a second now look tommy
lauren is not particularly conservative
tommy lahren famously not only defended
abortion but accused conservatives
pro-life
people who oppose abortion of being
hypocrites
because conservatives you see support
limited government
but they also don't think we should kill
a million babies a year
so isn't that hypocrisy it's obviously
not hypocrisy preventing the murder of a
million babies a year i think falls
within the legitimate limits of
government
okay no matter how limited you want your
government to be i think that's fair i
think that's within the bounds as
is by the way in this case
standing by the plain basic
fact of reality that men and women
are different now tommy lauren seems to
be saying that the observation that men
and women
are different is beyond the legitimate
limits of government so what are the are
you just an anarchist then you just
you think the government has no no
legitimate use
whatsoever tommy goes on the
conservatives quote unquote attacking
caitlyn for her personal choices
attacked trump for his and declared him
to be adverse to christian values
they were the bulk of the never trump
pearl clutching movement
that suddenly became real quiet when his
policies worked save your bs
what this that part just doesn't make
any sense at all the people that i look
i know the plural of anecdote is not
data
the people i know who oppose the caitlyn
jenner candidacy on the grounds that men
who
are under the false impression that
they're women
definitely need to figure things out and
probably should not be holding public
office and
probably are not the most conservative
candidates told public office
the ones i know who hold that view tend
to be trump's supporters
the ones that i know who are squishy on
the issue of transgenderism
they tend to fall more in the never
trump camp i'm just speaking anecdotally
but i i it's simply a fact that men
men and women are different and
i don't think there's anything bigoted
or hypocritical about pointing that out
also also caitlyn jenner
bruce jenner distanced himself from
trump he backed away from
he sort of liked trump initially and
then he stopped liking trump and
famously he said he doesn't even care
about the republican party
his loyalties do not lie with the
republican party or with donald trump
his loyalty and his concern
is for the lgbt movement
my loyalties do not lie with donald
trump my loyalty to not lie with the
republican party
my loyalties and what i'm fighting for
is my community the lgbt community and
particularly the trans issues that are
out there
because there are many of them um and so
that's where my fight is and
i thought trump would be pretty good but
he's kind of disappointed me in the
first hundred days
okay well when he says it believe him
his
his issue is not conservatism his issue
is not the gop his issue is not make
america great again
it's lgbt and specifically transgender
is pushing transgenderism
oh okay not my candidate then should not
be any of our candidates i mentioned
this not to pick on
bruce jenner and not to pick on tommy
lahren even but just to point out
you've got a very prominent conservative
commentator on the prominent
conservative cable network pushing this
stuff
that would have been considered as far
left as it possibly gets even five years
ago
viva siempre la revolucion apparently
hold up i'm glad you like that clip
go check out the full episode it's
called the perpetual revolution you can
get it here on youtube you ring that
bell you subscribe you get the
notifications
you can get it on apple podcast spotify
google play stitcher myspace saying a
live journal wherever wherever you get
your podcasts
we have got a revolution going on here
folks we are going to upend
the ruling dominant desiccated corrupt
liberal regime
but we need your help to do it go check
out all that stuff and viva
siempre la revolucion
[Music]
you